when I look up and I make some  calculations and I I make some  scientific experiments about the  physical world I can discover that the  Earth revolves around the Sun so that  means the Earth is not at the center of  the solar system or the center of the  universe but metaphysically speaking is  man is the meeting of the physical body  with with the rational Soul if a man is  in a deeper sense the center of the  cosmos so which is it is man the center  of the universe or not well because  metaphysical reality is more fundamental  Than Physical reality physical reality  is contingent on metaphysical reality  that's why it's metaphysical it's beyond  physics I I think it is truer and more  profound to say that man is the center  of the universe but for the purposes of  making certain physical calculations I  think it's fair enough to say that the  Earth revolves around the Sun